il est l'un des meilleurs ambassadeurs
de la ville de Blois l'escalier Denis
Papin l'escalier aux multiples visages
10 ans déjà vous en découvrez vous allez
en découvrir quelques-unes de ces
affiches on peut citer par exemple la
spirale magique de 2018 pour les 20 ans
de la maison de la magie ou encore la
Joconde en 2019 pour les 500 ans de la
Renaissance 3 millions de vues sur les
réseaux sociaux un escalier à la fois
œuvre d'art et support promotionnel pour
des événements et c'est évidemment
encore casse cette année à l'occasion
d'un festival de photographie Elaine
chapelet nous plonge dans les secrets de
ce monument à part
donc là du coup on va venir chauffer
l'adhésif
et on vient l'appuyer avec notre
roulette pour qu'il épouse bien la forme
de la pierre
c'est la deuxième fois que Cyril
participe à la décoration de l'escalier
Denis Papin cet après-midi là les 120
contre marche ne sont pas encore toutes
recouvertes il reste la partie
supérieure à finaliser d'en bas pourtant
le visuel prend forme disons déjà que le
lieu change de physionomie au gré des
saisons et depuis 2013 toujours la même
entreprise partenaire pour effectuer ce
relooking
c'est un adhésif sans PVC donc c'est qui
est enlevable sans résidu de colle c'est
important on ne met pas de protection UV
sur cette adhésif parce qu'on va être
sur un projet qui est à terme de six
mois pas plus sur certaines opérations
un peu moins une cure de rajeunissement
pour cette escalier qui date de 1865 un
décor original dont se sert également
cette commerçante bléoise entre deux
passages de voitures Alexandra prend la
pose pour présenter les dernières pièces
de sa collection de prêt-à-porter une
habitude amorcée pendant le confinement
et qui perdure chaque saison le décor
change donc on fait les photos devant
l'escalier donc on voit l'escalier au
loin ça change de voilà de décor et
c'est plutôt sympathique les gens sont
hyper friands de ça en fait le nouvel
habillage est un photomontage réalisé
par un duo d'artiste grec il sert
d'annonce pour les 19e Promenades
Photographiques qui s'installeront à
Blois du 30 juin au 30 août coup pour la
municipalité
10000 euros entre l'impression et la
pose des lait c'est d'abord une volonté
d'amener l'art sur l'espace public parce
que c'est un terrain de jeu formidable
pour les artistes et puis aussi de
mettre à disposition l'art à tout le
monde donc à tous les gens qui passent
dans le centre-ville c'est aussi pour la
ville d'asseoir sa notoriété son image
donc avec tous les postes qu'il y a sur
Facebook sur les réseaux sociaux
effectivement la ville marque son image
et on se dit tiens ce sont les escaliers
de Blois
ce décor restera en place jusqu'au
rendez-vous de l'Histoire en octobre
prochain